it's spring and while temperatures are
rising we're seeing more pesky insects
crawling around and flying as well 8
news now reporter Madison Kimbrough
spoke with a professor at UNLV about
what he's seen on campus along with
those who say they've seen an uptick in
bugs this season
it's not going to make a difference
they're still going to come it's it's
the valley it's hot
the season tis the season for bugs
they're all around us but it seems like
more people across the valley are taking
notice we posted this on our 8 news now
Facebook page and look over 350
responses no doubt Las Vegas have a lot
to say about it some people get really
freaked out by them they're completely
harmless UNLV professor of Life Sciences
Alan Gibbs says just recently those over
at the Richard Tam Alumni Center had
their own encounter with what they refer
to as a moth outbreak in their building
if you want to keep them away from your
house
one thing you can do is they're they're
attracted to ultraviolet light and
bright lights
so they don't like yellow light as much
so if you just change out your outdoor
bulbs to yellow lights you'll get fewer
moths and here at Bob Baskin Park many
share what they've seen in just the last
couple of weeks when it comes to these
creepy crawlers the moths are in the
house now
yeah they're all over the house I have
been noticing that and Christina
tischner says she has seen a variety of
bugs come through the hotel lobby where
she works on the Strip we've been seeing
a lot of bugs coming through the doors
dead crickets walking you know in the
windows it's just this is the time of
the year that it comes out here every
year at Bob Baskin Park Madison
Kimbrough eight news now
and while spring is the season for moths
ants and grasshoppers to name a few to
come out in full force good news these
types of insects typically move to
cooler climates by the end of June